a lot of people made a big deal
obviously you've talked about it I mean
you and um and Kendall Jenner are
friends but the whole Coachella thing
you said that you Spence
[ __ ] that's crazy that that's a big we
went to Buffalo Wild Wings the other day
is some random [ __ ] came up like yo I
don't know the dude's name that he said
[ __ ] kendall Jenner and that was so cool
you're sitting with there I'm no no well
see oh I'm just like is that really news
like oh my god why I'm asking because I
know you said you I think you said that
you were my eternal love for Nia has a
drought hey we all walk and [ __ ] are
fully hyped on the fact someone said
[ __ ] Hindu Jenner but what's the reason
why I bring it up is because I know
you've spent a lot of time with her
family and they just did the Bruce
Jenner thing last night have you ever
met her pops did you and your wife a
matter of dad did you watch the
interview at all nah you have any
thoughts on that I don't know this about
that he's that key admit he's
transitioning to a woman and that's so
cool
it's pretty crazy that's actually really
tight I'm telling you man if I could
transition to like a tree or it's just
anything I will [ __ ] do if you could
transit if you could be anything but but
but the the dude that you are if you
could transition into like you said a
tree what would it be man what would you
turn yourself into obviously besides
either a bird or a Jeep a G yeah that's
some redneck dude you drive me that's
some Florida [ __ ] right I don't know
crocodiles touch me and she'll be sick
that'd be tight mud all over me as
though he said it I use the way I'm
supposed to